speaking of guys you penned a letter
this week from a female perspective to
Bernie Sanders I've written about this
several times from a male perspective
and then we got in the phone and you
went into a rant I said this needs a
female perspective so telethia it's
called when I have a deer burn a deer
man who vote Bernie Sanders you're not
men at all and you received so much hate
mail I did from a lot of men who would
who somehow were trying to defend their
manhood by saying no but really I am a
man just because I want Bernie Sanders
doesn't mean I'm not a man think okay
I'm not even gonna not even gonna give
that a response
you only have time real men if I'm gonna
respond to a tweet or email no no no I
even had some wives like well my husband
works he's full-time and he volunteers
but he's voting for Bernie Sanders and
how dare you like really yeah I don't
think your husband's volunteering I
think he can go on down to the local gay
bar and find him ducking you that's what
I think okay so you wrote this and I've
talked about this I don't believe that
in 2016 you can be a man and be an
actual full-fledged progressive I don't
mean the kind of like a liberal maybe
pro-abortion or things I mean full-on
Bernie socialist I've written about that
what was your main point here in this
article that people hated you so much
well the idea that men have to provide
for themselves and provide for their
family can just I can see myself on the
camera and it's very distracting because
she's so good-looking that's why I got
the vitamin D watch this is gonna become
a gift and then everyone the rumors of
do to get in full shot there yeah all
right go ahead Courtney try want to
distract that yeah men don't need other
men to provide for them or their
families they also don't need a
politician to demand that other people
give no demand that their tax dollars be
taken to give to other people who refuse
to work for them to work for them
so real men provide for themselves
provide for their families they don't
whine they don't say it's not fair that
so-and-so has more they don't excuse why
they're not successful or blame it on
white privilege they don't do that they
say screw it I see a challenge challenge
accepted I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna
be successful despite all of these
things that I have going against me
Bernie Sanders voters don't do that they
believe Barack Obama they believe Bernie
Sanders when they say oh the deck is
stacked against you you didn't build
that we can help you you deserve your
fair share and these rich people who've
just glided through life they're gonna
they're gonna pay for you it's it's okay
we're gonna take care of you that's not
a man
that's a [ __ ] and I'm not sorry I'm not
sorry
I don't think we have to keep that
referring to them yeah stop it stop it
because I know Courtney will go there
she's a she's a lady but she's she's a
lady who's willing she will go there and
I don't want her to go there right now
yeah I agree with you I agree with you
and I I just don't have a lot in common
with guys like that and I think you can
have it with wealthy people too I mean
they think you said with rich guys who
feel they have to prove because some
things have been handed to them as
opposed to people who are self built but
particularly it is the ideology of a
Bernie voter to subscribe to it you have
to believe that someone else is pulling
the strings and it's not in your control
and I just see that as anti rugged
individualists but as a woman is it does
it actually like could you ever date a
leftist no I don't think so you choked
on your words if I were to see like a
guy pull up in a Prius with that Bernie
Sanders sticker or a Darwin fish instead
of the Jesus fish it we're done we don't
we're done yeah I couldn't I couldn't
it's not anything against people who
drive Priuses some people like the car
fine but no nobody likes the car well
these are if you're a people pleaser and
you want people to like you and you want
everybody know how much you care for the
poor or whatever
I can't can't it's gross well you want
someone who cares for the poor you just
don't som want someone who advertises
this to pick up trash okay look at if
you care for the poor great care for the
poor with your own money don't mandate
other people's money go to something
that you say like it's not charity
yeah I love how they separate that is a
fiscal issue well isn't that kind of a
moral issue wouldn't we put that on the
lid on that side of the ledger yeah it's
it's it's interesting to hear a woman
say that because my dad and I have
talked about that as men but now is this
something that I know when we write
about this thing sometimes we think up
ideas for columns is this something that
has been percolating for a while you've
always felt that way and it was just
sort of sort of cathartic to put it to
paper or it was it in aha no I've always
thought this I kind of think liberal man
is an oxymoron I don't think you can be
a liberal and be a man and I know and I
mean that in a masculine you can't be
masculine you can be a male adult but I
don't think of you as being masculine if
if you espouse liberal ideas and if you
live by the liberal ideas there are a
lot of successful men successful people
who stay liberal things that they don't
they aren't liberal in their own lives
they're conservative in their own lives
they're men in their own lives but if
you can just if you just even know
around expresser disgust but that's true
greg gutfeld made that point that anyone
who's successful had to do so through
the pillars of conservatism of taking
upon themselves Andras personal
responsibility I wish I could find that
but Greg Gutfeld Google is a pretty
University Prager University
yep guy does some great stuff okay
Courtney will bring you on after this
break to anger some more men and maybe
find some suitors louder with creditors
stay tuned for more Courtney hey you're
still here that's surprising I'm not
going to lie this is the Internet most
people have an attention span of four
seconds but this is a clip taken from
the full weekly videocast podcast you
can click below to watch that full video
cast or subscribe on iTunes or
SoundCloud click my face it allotted
with credit com where there are more
articles than you could read in a
lifetime or click below me where there's
another video it's shorter because I
know you're busy and you have things to
do like find pants